Das Pfarrhaus Globig in Sachsen-Anhalt
hat schon bessere Zeiten erlebt.
Es wird eingeheizt, denn gleich trifft
sich hier die Seniorengruppe,
wie jeden Mittwoch. Allerdings:
Bald ist damit Schluss.
Pfarrer Jürgen Hofmann muss
das Pfarrhaus aufgeben.
Es ist niemand mehr da, der sich um
den maroden Altbau kümmert.
In Globig haben wir jetzt das Problem,
dass die Mieter ausziehen.
Und wir haben … das ist ein Haus,
wo zwar die Fenster neu sind
und das Dach neu sind [ist],
aber eben keine Heizung drin ist.
Und da ist es ganz, ganz schwer,
neue Nachmieter jetzt zu finden,
in dieser Zeit, dass wir uns entschlossen
haben, das Haus zu verkaufen.
Ein Pfarrhaus macht zu, das erlebt
Hofmann nicht zum ersten Mal.
Diesmal wird es wenigstens
eine Ersatzbleibe geben.
Er hofft, dass die kleine Gemeinde
zusammenhält
und setzt dabei auch auf Gottes Hilfe.
Das ist sowieso etwas,
was Gott ganz oft tut, dass wir …
dass er uns die Wünsche erfüllt,
die wir ganz tief im Herzen haben.
Aber es kommen immer weniger Gläubige
zu den Gottesdiensten und Andachten.
Der leibliche Genuss mit Stachelbeer-
und Käsekuchen –
für den Pfarrer ein probates Mittel,
um Luthers Lehren zu vermitteln.
Ja, das war jetzt Globig, wir gehen jetzt
in den Nachbarort, nach Wartenburg,
da trifft sich der Mütterkreis um halb vier.
Das schaffen wir gut, und dann
geht’s wieder weiter.
Fulltime-Job zwischen Seniorenkreis und
Müttergruppe: sieben Tage die Woche.
Über dreißig Kilometer erstrecken sich die
Dörfer der Kirchengemeinde Sankt Petri.
Die Nähe zu Wittenberg bringt nicht viel:
Nur ungefähr jeder zehnte ist hier noch
Mitglied der evangelischen Kirche.
Einstmals Wiege der Reformation, heute
eine gottverlassene Gegend?
Gottverlassen nicht, aber die Gegend hat
Gott vergessen, jedenfalls in weiten Teilen.
Also, die DDR war ja nicht sehr erfolgreich,
besonders wirtschaftlich nicht,
aber in der Politik der Religionsbekämpfung
war die DDR leider sehr erfolgreich,
und die Last haben wir jetzt
dadurch zu tragen.
Der Mütterkreis in Wartenburg –
eher ein Großmütterkreis.
Die Töchter und Enkelinnen fehlen.
Viele junge Frauen verlassen die Region,
um anderswo zu arbeiten.
Und die sieht man dann auch
nicht mehr in der Kirche.
Wenn sie dann auch Jugendweihe, äh,
Konfirmation hatten –
das ist ganz selten, dass da dann einer
noch kommt. Traurig, es ist so.
500 Jahre nach der Reformation in
Wittenberg
ist in der Region nicht viel übrig von der
Idee der Kirche fürs ganze Volk.
Das Volk interessiert sich nicht.
Wenigstens den Kontakt zum
Nachwuchs nicht verlieren,
dafür ist Hofmann Vorsitzender
des CVJM Wittenberg,
des „Christlichen Vereins junger Menschen“.
Immerhin hier hat das Lutherjahr
einen Schub gebracht.
Aus einem Sommerprojekt ist ein
dauerhafter Jugendtreff geworden.
Wir hoffen, dass die Kinder mal fragen,
warum machst du das denn eigentlich?
Und dass man dann unsere
Mitarbeiter sagen:
Jawoll, ich mach das, weil ich an Gott
glaube, weil ich Kontakt zu Jesus hab, ja,
und was bedeutet das.
Und dann kommen dann
solche Gespräche.
Der Pfarrer sieht sich ohnehin nicht als
Vorbeter für die schweigende Gemeinde,
sondern eher als Trainer für diejenigen,
die ihren Glauben entdecken –
ganz im Sinne Martin Luthers.
Wir hatten ja in Deutschland immer
Volkskirche gehabt,
das heißt, da war das ganze
Volk in der Kirche.
Jetzt müssen wir ein anderes
Paradigma bekommen:
Wir sind … die Kirche muss für das Volk
da sein,
das derzeit nicht in der Kirche ist.
Denn jeden Sonntag aufs Neue ist
er mit einer halbleeren Kirche konfrontiert.
Pfarrer Hofmann kämpft um jeden
Besucher seines Gottesdiensts.
Alle vier Wochen spielt die Jugendband,
dann kommen immer ein paar Leute mehr
als sonst in die Kirche.
Und sie sollen eben nicht nur zuhören.
Ich bitte euch jetzt einmal,
die Augen jetzt zu schließen.
Lasst ein inneres Bild entstehen, von dem,
was ich gleich vorlesen werde.
Gott sitzt auf dem Thron und
wird gepriesen.
Heilig, heilig, heilig ist Gott der Herr,
der allmächtige Herrscher.
Der Glaube bringt den Menschen zu Gott,
so die Lehre Martin Luthers.
Pfarrer Hofmann kämpft 500
Jahre später darum,
dass überhaupt noch Menschen die
Botschaft des Reformators hören wollen.